what is going on everybody welcome back
to the cosmic wonder I'm Warren Thompson
and 2022 is almost over and 2023 is just
a few days away and what's really
exciting is that we are only a couple of
months away from phase five actually we
are less than two months away as Ant-Man
and the WASP Quantum Mania comes out
February 17th of next year and with that
starts phase five of the Marvel
Cinematic Universe and things are about
to go down it's about to get really
serious in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
despite whatever you felt for phase four
whether you hated it or loved it fangs
are about to change and I'll walk you
through it in this video if you're in
love with the MCU as it is already
you're gonna be even more excited and if
you are kind of on the fence right now
listen to this video and tell me at the
end if you have changed your mind or not
because I truly believe that it's about
to get insanely exciting so what exactly
is about to go down in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe that is going to be
such a big change from phase four well
as most people know phase 4 was very
much an experimental and a rebuilding
phase we ended the infinity Saga with
Avengers endgame and then we started a
new saga the Multiverse Saga and with
the start of a very new beginning some
of our old iconic classic characters
leaving us of course there had to be new
characters introduced to the MCU but not
all of the old original characters left
now some of them are taking more of the
spotlight and we had to focus on their
story a little bit more as well so
naturally things had to be built up
again but keep in mind Avengers endgame
and infinity War didn't come in phase
one or two phase one two and three built
up to Avengers Infinity war and end game
happening that is what Marvel Studios
has done with phase four and it's all
about to be connected and it's about to
go down starting with Ant-Man and the
WASP Quantum Mania now phase 4 teased us
with the Multiverse and I really mean
teased us because we thought we were
going to go all in with Multiverse
Madness and Loki but it really was just
a teaser now Loki did an excellent job
of introducing us to variants Spider-Man
no way home also did an excellent job
job and Doctor Strange in the Multiverse
of Madness kind of topped it off but
here's what's really about to happen in
the MCU here's how everything is about
to be very connected it all starts in
Phase five with Kang with Ant-Man 3 we
are going to be introduced to the True
Villain of the Multiverse Saga however
we are not just going to be introduced
to one villain slash King but multiple
Kings some of which might even be good a
very small percentage but some might and
what Kang will introduce to us is the
true power of a villain who can travel
throughout the Multiverse at his own
will this makes him a very dangerous
villain because he can go not only to
different universes but to different
times in different universes and keep
this in mind some universes are more
advanced than the others this is
actually what makes Kang so powerful he
can go to more advanced universes and he
can go forward in time to go even more
advanced and he can take their
technology and their weapons and
whatever it may be and bring them to the
current main sacred timeline of the MCU
and wherever else he wants for that
matter so right away he's an extremely
dangerous villain because of the power
that he harnesses being able to jump
through the Multiverse at will then
comes secret Invasion after Ant-Man and
the WASP quantumania this is going to be
a lot more important than people realize
because it's going to show us that
perhaps some things that we knew about
the MCU we didn't really know we know
that the scroll are going to be
disguised as probably some of the people
we thought we knew we got a little taste
of this in Spider-Man far from home
Talos was disguised as Nick Fury and we
didn't know he was and it was revealed
that Nick Fury was actually in space now
Talos a good Creed did that for good but
there are bad Cree out there who are
going to disguise themselves as very
prominent people for bad so what we
think we might know about the MCU might
actually be shattered with secret
Invasion then comes the Guardians of the
Galaxy and this is going to be big
because this is going to be the end of
the Guardians of the Galaxy but at the
same time it isn't going to be the
complete end we are going to get a new
Guardians of the Galaxy team so going
forward leading into the King Dynasty in
secret Wars will have a completely new
Guardians team and what's really cool is
the possibilities of who could be on
this team Nova could be on this team
Adam Warlock could be on this team after
Guardians 3. depending on what they
decide to do with the Silver Surfer he
could also be a part of the Guardians
team so the future of the Guardians of
the Galaxy are going to be very exciting
then comes the echo series and I'm going
to jump ahead just a little bit here in
the Daredevil Series this is going to
bring us our street level Avengers team
and it's going to bring Kingpin back
into the MCU after Hawkeye again and
hopefully if rumors are true this All
Leads up to the street level Avengers
team teaming up with Spider-Man to go up
against Kingpin and other amazing
villains but then we have Loki season 2
and this is really going to change
things this is going to show us a true
king the Conqueror somebody who has
conquered the TVA and is controlling it
for himself we will be introduced into
even more variants we've already seen
that with the teaser for Loki season 2
that we got from Disney but most
importantly we are going to see how Kang
controls time in different timelines
this is going to really dive deep into
who King the Conqueror is and what all
he can do then we have the Marvels which
are going to connect us to the cosmic
side of the MCU even more along with
Guardians of the Galaxy but what's
really important about this movie is the
Bengal that Kamala Khan has this is
directly linked to Kang along with Shang
Chi's tin Rings they are both the same
technology there's also a pretty big
rumor going around and it's just a rumor
for now but the rumor says that Rogue
could possibly appear in the Marvels now
her and Captain Marvel have a long
history together in the comics and I for
one would love to see this happen on
screen but it's just a rumor for now now
we're only about halfway done with phase
five we still have the rest of the half
and we still have phase six but right
now let me know how you're feeling about
the mcu's future in the comments down
below are you getting more excited than
you were before and if you are not let's
talk about mafis still and let's talk
about him in a very real way not in a
meme way but a real way according to
many different insiders that have great
track records Mephisto was going to
appear in the Iron Heart series now
they're not going to address him as
Mephisto but what he is being referred
to as far as we know so far is a demon
now in the ironheart series we know that
the hood is going to be the main villain
and apparently according to these
insiders like my time to shine hello the
hood is going to get his powers from
making a deal with Mephisto and if you
haven't heard Mephisto was supposed to
be played by Sasha Baron Cohen Borat
himself and there has actually been
leaked concept art of what he will look
like in this series but unfortunately I
can't show it on screen due to copyright
but if you just look for it you can find
it and then we have blade and blade is
just going to open up a completely new
side of the MCU werewolf by Knight
started us off but then blade is going
to really take it to the next level
basically starting the Supernatural and
the monster side of the MCU we're
talking vampires where wolves monsters
you name it and we're talking about
characters that could appear in the
midnight Suns so blade is going to kick
it off and going to open it up for
characters like Ghost Rider and the
Black Knight which has already been
teased and to top that all off we have
Agatha coven of chaos which is going to
take us even further into that darker
more mystical and magical side of the
MCU and to top it all off Phase 5 is
going to end with Captain America New
World Order and the Thunderbolts now so
far what we've heard about both of these
movies is pretty crazy Captain America
New World Order is kind of going to be
about super soldier serum also Harrison
Ford is joining the MCU and Captain
America new world order as Thaddeus
Thunderbolt Ross and if it is all about
super soldier serum we are probably
going to see him Hulk out and turn into
Red Hulk it's also said that this movie
is going to have about six different
Villains The Leader being one of them as
well it's also said that the new
Avengers team is going to start to be
assembled in this movie so here's where
it starts to really really pick up going
into our new Avengers films the kingdom
Dynasty and Secret Wars but the big
finale of Captain America New World
Order could be that it introduces a
major X-Men and Wolverine connection
because according to some insiders like
Daniel rpk and my time to shine hello in
Captain America 4 the world governments
are going to be fighting over the head
and possibly the rest of the body of the
celestial that died in the eternals on
Earth Tiamat apparently the body of
Tiamat contains adamantium and if you
didn't happen to know adamantium is the
metal that Wolverine has fused inside of
his body it's also mentioned that the
head could serve as gnosha Island which
in the comics is basically a base camp
eventually for the mutants but to top it
all off we are getting a new team and of
course the grand finale of phase five
the introduction of Sentry to the MCU
Sentry is supposed to be the villain of
the Thunderbolts he's going to start off
on the Thunderbolts team but then he's
going to start to kind of go crazy
hearing voices in his head then the
Thunderbolts are going to have to kill
him but if you know anything about
Sentry that's pretty impossible but this
movie will introduce entry into the MCU
and eventually he should go on to become
a hero and hopefully he goes on to fight
in secret Wars and that does it for
Phase 5 but it only gets even better in
phase six now we already know about the
two Avengers movies coming in phase six
Avengers the King Dynasty is going to
connect a lot of things that we didn't
really see were connected at first like
I mentioned before Xiang Chi's 10 rings
and Kamal Khan's Bengal being connected
like I also mentioned before there are
going to be many different variants of
King this is what he who remains told us
would happen if Loki and Sylvie killed
him essentially there would be another
all-out multiversal War but remember the
multiversal war wasn't between just
random different universes it was all
between King and his variants so it
really was a Kang War but what the Kang
Dynasty is going to show us is who the
real true big bad King is so this is
going to be a huge staple people in the
story leading up to Secret Wars now of
course in Phase 6 Marvel's first family
is making their way to the MCU the
Fantastic Four this gives us the
introduction to one of the greatest
superhero teams of all time and to read
Richards the smartest man alive in the
Marvel Universe not only is the
introduction of the Fantastic Four going
to permanently change the MCU but the
Avengers are going to need the Fantastic
Four to defeat Kang and save the
Multiverse the introduction of the
smartest man alive and his team are how
the Avengers and everybody else who's
going to be a part of that group are
going to figure out how to travel the
Multiverse I feel like I don't really
need to Hype people for the Fantastic
Four's arrival I feel like it's already
there but they are going to be extremely
important and insanely cool but then of
course not officially announced yet for
a release date but we get Deadpool 3.
now even if this movie was simply just
Wolverine and Deadpool Hugh Jackman and
Ryan Reynolds sitting in a car for two
hours it would still probably be one of
the best things to ever come from the
Marvel Cinematic Universe but we know
the TVA is going to be involved we know
that Owen Wilson's Mobius will be in
there and we know that Deadpool is going
to be traveling the Multiverse running
into the old X-Men the old Fantastic
Four and who knows who else so while I'm
sure the movie is going to have some
consequences for the MCU since the TVA
is chasing Deadpool I'm honestly just
ready for the comedy and just Deadpool
and Wolverine to interact with each
other because Hugh Jackman is back and
we never thought we'd see that and now
he's on screen with one of his best
friends Ryan Reynolds it's going to be
awesome now Somewhere In the Mix of
Phase 5 and phase six is another
Spider-Man film most likely in phase six
but hey it could be in Phase five a lot
of people are really excited for this
because Peter Parker rmcu Peter Parker
Tom Holland is finally going to be on
his own he's not gonna kind of be
babysat by anybody like Tony Stark or
Nick Fury or Talos disguised as Nick
Fury or happy or the other two
Spider-Man but he is finally going to be
on his own which is super exciting in
and of itself but then you take into
account that he's probably going to lead
the street level Avengers team and
interact with people like Daredevil
She-Hulk can go up against Kingpin that
makes it even more exciting and to top
it off we are supposed to get projects
for the Silver Surfer and Nova now
recently these were reportedly supposed
to be special presentations however new
reports have come out that state that
they are going to be actual movies so we
should have the Silver Surfer which
should also be a good indicator that
Galactus is coming and Nova so they
should be apart for Secret Wars and of
course to end it all to end the
Multiverse Saga we have Avengers Secret
Wars where not just the Avengers not
just the Fantastic Four not just the
X-Men but all of the different ones in
all of the different universes are going
to come together to try to save the
entire Multiverse from King the
Conqueror and who knows who else with
this movie literally anything is
possible I've said this before but
Batman could show up it's literally
possible now that that James Gunn is the
CEO co-ceo of DC Studios he has talked
about a DC Marvel crossover before he
has pitched it to both Marvel and DC
perhaps we may get a small Cameo for
Batman or somebody else from DC in
secret Wars literally anything is
possible and that alone makes this movie
Just One of the most anticipated movies
of all time and that's how the
Multiverse Saga is going to end now as a
Marvel fan this all excites me a great
deal but let me know what you think are
you excited about this and if you
weren't and you are now please let me
know in the comments and if you're not
well let me know why you're not excited
about it and don't forget to like the
video and subscribe so you don't miss
out on any of the future videos for live
updates you can always follow us on
Instagram and Twitter and as always
thank you all so much for watching wolf
wolf
baby